all right
i'm gonna go live i'm gonna go live a
little bit early
uh since we already have a lot of
questions piled up
and address as many of these as i can so
we'll go for about an hour and a half
today's a day where i got some good
video work done in the morning
for my bio medical ethics class
and i've got um some work to do tonight
and a lot of work to do over the course
of the day but take a little break
to answer these questions so matthew
hopkins has a slew of questions about a
car
i'll answer a few of them um can you
talk a little bit about the way
descartes uses god in the meditations he
seems to just use the idea to give him
his fixed point
to ground his epistemology but it seems
a little clumsy and maybe
unnecessary does descartes system stand
up without god
so descartes is crystal clear that his
system does not hold up without god
and i think we should probably take him
at his word for that he wasn't just
giving lip service to it
and it's um you know it's it's the
philosopher's god right
descartes certainly did believe in some
sort of deism he
he was officially a catholic but didn't
seem particular
uh rarely talks about jesus or anything
like that
in his his works or letters
so you know um you can definitely
say though that his conception of god is
really central to
his his uh his system um there's three
kinds of substances
bodies minds and then the substance that
is god
you need god in order to get the mileage
out of
a lot of things in descartes work that
descartes wants to
to get out of it and you know in his uh
discussions in the objections and
replies you'll see him
you know fleshing out this this concept
a little bit more
so i wouldn't buy pascal's idea it's a
great quip that
descartes brought god in you know as to
get things started and then after that
no use for him whatsoever
god plays an important role in descartes
metaphysics
and his epistemology
but you know it's not a particularly
christian god it's not the god of
classical theism it's a rather abstract
kind of
kind of being so um i think it's always
best when we're looking at philosophers
and their conception of
god and this would go not just for
descartes but also for
you know the other rationalists this
would go for
the various empiricists this would go
for you know later
philosophers this would go for ancient
philosophers and it would even go for
medieval philosophers don't always
assume that they have exactly
the same thing in mind you got to go to
their texts and dig in and see what
they've what they've got going on there
what their vision or depiction of god
happens to be all right so galen asks
thoughts on leo strauss's commentaries
on philosophical texts
especially ancient texts not about him
or the arguments or
about his legacy but is he a good
secondary source when using a secondary
so that's a good question um strauss can
be an
interesting secondary source i would
never rely on him as your sole secondary
source any more than i would rely on
bertrand russell
or you know william durant or any of
these people who really clearly have a
story that they want to tell
about the the history of philosophy
um but you know the stuff that he has to
say is interesting i've i've
you know cited him when appropriate um
on occasion you know he actually also
edited a pretty good
big volume and i'm blanking on its name
it's about political
theory it's got all these great essays
in it by by different people
um so you know he's he's a decent source
um i would say
you know if you had to pick a one single
secondary source
strauss would never be my go-to um
but he's certainly interesting he's
interesting like in the same way deleuze
is right
when you read de luz's book on nietzsche
or bergstone
or leibniz you're definitely getting
allotted to lose
or like kojov is that way with hegel
right you're getting more kojov than
you're getting hegel
but it's it's interesting stuff so you
know is he worth reading he's worth
reading
he's one of these secondary sources
where he's far enough away from the
original
that he's not providing you just like a
scholarly commentary he's providing with
his own
his own shtick you could say good to see
mark smith here
um my my collaborator and and friend
and uh how have i been keeping
so it has been like a perfect storm of
busyness because we had you know the
usual i'm teaching six
classes this semester right so there's a
lot of a lot of work already involved
with that and it's six
different classes all of which are
online three different institutions
long journey again more classes than
they intended to because schools were
they needed somebody to fill in and and
i was the person that
could do it um so you know you gotta as
they say
make hay while the sun shines right um
but that's been a big drag of course the
election and all the uncertainty with
respect to that
has been weighing heavily on my students
minds and
colleagues minds and other people i
haven't been that affected
by it myself but you know doing
exercises for resiliency helps with that
sort of thing
i've been super busy with last month we
had stoic con we had stoic week we had
several different stoic on exes they're
still going on
i you know spoke at two of them and
ran another one so that kept me pretty
busy
and then there was you know some illness
in in our family so
all of that has kept me pretty busy i'm
really looking forward to thanksgiving
week because i'm going to take a break
and
not do much of anything although i i
might do some like um
live streaming you know uh if i feel
like it
so i'm looking forward to the semester
getting to a close
and i'm you know things are going okay i
would say
um things could be a lot worse and so
that's you know that's good
all right arc of a das enjoyed your
articles on the body as an indifferent
in your renewed renewing use of it in
your workouts
uh what has been your most significant
experience in exercising control over
nutrition well i mean to begin with i
would just i wouldn't call it nutrition
that's a
kind of clinical way of talking about it
and i don't think about eating
in in those sorts of terms i don't
instrumentalize it
i i'm somebody you know my wife works
for
the food business school of the culinary
institute of america we've had a
long-standing connection we're
tapped into the food scene so we think
of food and stuff that we enjoy
to eat and then we think of nutrition
almost secondarily
um but you know you're supposed to take
care of your body
and so you know we we avoid eating too
much
take out or processed food we don't need
a lot of crap
but that's not something new i mean
we've been doing that for years and
years and years because
that's the rational way to live it's
also the way by the way if you grew up
uh in the kind of household that my wife
and i did
where you cook from scratch because you
don't have a lot of money
and because it's also a healthy way to
do things and you watch your parents
doing that and everybody
else in your family doing that it's kind
of second nature
you know for us
slumming would be dropping some pasta in
and using a jar of canned sauce it's
pretty rare that
i would actually not make spaghetti
sauce from
from scratch or if i am doing a jar
there's some other stuff going into it
right
um so you know there haven't been an
awful lot of changes
on on my part um you know maybe a little
less carbs and things
making a few less desserts but but
that's about it
you know we we eat healthy most of the
time already
jeff says i know this is pretty
open-ended what are your thoughts on
drinking i've seen you drinking beer in
certain videos what kind of drinks do
you like
um you know drinking like many other
things is okay in moderation
um if you wake up in the morning and you
need to have a drink
you got a problem and you better better
attend to it this by the way
you know wisconsin is a heavy drinking
state
and i went to schools that were heavy
drinking places you know
i mean i started drinking uh beer
and liquor when i was in middle school
well actually wine too because we'd go
on like camping trips or stuff like that
and there'd always be some kid who'd you
know raided his his dad's liquor cabinet
had some brandy
or the parents would have some wine for
their own consumption and we would get
into it or
somebody would you know in high school
somebody would be old enough
to uh have an uncle or some friend
or an army buddy because some people
were in the reserves and they could buy
us
cases of beer so you know i i started
drinking pretty early
i certainly have seen my share of abuse
of alcohol
and you know when you spend time with
hardcore alcoholics
who are like decades in and you see how
crappy their life is that can be a good
dissuader
from from you know going down that path
but
i think there's there's nothing
intrinsically wrong with it
it's definitely something that we now
know more about
in terms of its effects on the body um
so you know it's it's something to to
exercise in moderation it's kind of nice
in that it does help we call it a social
lubricant right
because it lowers people's inhibitions
you don't want people drinking too much
i actually
in my business ethics classes here in
wisconsin towards the end of the
semester when we're discussing
christmas parties we talk about how many
how many drinks can you have
should you have one two three or if it's
an open bar as many as you can pack in
and you know the student consensus is
usually between two and three
and then and then get get yourself out
of there which is pretty prudent
so you can say you know drinking is part
of temperance and drinking is part of
prudence
um now what kind of drinks do i like
uh you know i like beers um
i like good beers so i i don't like uh
most of the beers that made milwaukee
famous like perhaps blue ribbon which is
for
you know foolish hipsters because it's
really piss i don't like budweiser
which is like basically watered down
piss i don't like miller light
which is watered down as well those are
all american pilsners and they're not
they're not very good
they're from our legacy of prohibition
and the real breweries closing
and they did provide a lot of jobs in
this area um and there are a few beers
that they made that were okay like you
know
in high school we drank miller genuine
draft but then you know once
i got germany as a soldier started
drinking good stuff
and i came here to wisconsin and started
drinking some of the
here this is one of the places where the
early microbrews were right with
schrecker brewery which is still around
almost recently changed hands because
the guy retired
um you know having access to good beers
and then i started brewing my own beer
when i was in college
and then after graduate school for a
while so
so you know i make the kind of stuff
that i wanted and experiment
a lot i like stuff that's got some real
real body and bite to it
you know i i really i like
ipas i don't like gimmicky ipas
where they put out all sorts of extra
crap in there that doesn't need to be in
there they kind of tinker with the the
hops too much
i like visin a lot i like stouts and
porters
so you know and i'll even occasionally
drink a pilsner on a hot day
i mean good pilsner is really good you
know like the stuff that you get from
uh uh you know actual german pilsners or
czech pilsners
um and i like some mixed drinks as well
uh i'm not a wine connoisseur i can't
really tell much
difference between good wine and bad
wine uh i like my wines
heavy and bitter and i like pork so
that's that's pretty much
it i don't drink that much anymore i
mean really it's it's like
the last time i had a drink was probably
when i was sick and i made myself a hot
toddy and that was weeks ago
so but i did i did certainly indulge a
lot when i was younger
all right isaac says do i have any
recommended prerequisites before
starting with kierkegaard and the
existentialists
or is the passing familiarity with plato
sufficient
um i mean plato
is good i would say
you know depends on the work of
kierkegaard right if you're
if you're thinking about um fear and
trembling
it could be good to know something about
hegel i don't think you have to actually
read hegel but
it might be useful to know what that
context is
um you know in other things i mean
kierkegaard references descartes at
different times he references pascal
[Music]
i don't think you absolutely have to
have
like an in-depth reading before doing
that but but it certainly helps right
and i think you should think of reading
as sort of an iterative process you go
back and forth and back and forth
other existentialists are drawing on on
other thinkers so
you know and by the time we get into
what we can call the second wave
of existentialism where we're we're
talking about
chest stuff and i think you could put
guillermes in there uh
as well and rylka
gabriel marcel is probably at the very
end of that second wave
uno muno uh ortega igassette in spain
heidegger definitely ospr's definitely
um i think you can say is kind of in
there
um and maybe boober um
i'd have to take a look at the dates on
that once you're in that second wave
you've got people who are referring to
the other
existentialists kierkegaard nietzsche
dostoevsky occasionally also people like
uh chest not chest chekov or
or tolstoy um so
you know if you're reading those figures
like if you're reading aspers you really
probably need to know something about
nietzsche and kierkegaard
um and so i guess that's probably
enough to say about that the other thing
is
you don't have to try to like you don't
have to try to master them all at once i
think it's okay to like read a book by
kierkegaard
and then go on to somebody else and then
come back to kierkegaard and read
another book right
and maybe i wouldn't actually start with
fear and trembling although i often do
use that as the introduction sickness
onto death is pretty good too
for that obviously the present age is is
one that's kind of useful
so all right uh
rap says do i have any recommendations
on which works to read after
kant in terms of epistemology um i mean
you could
read around in german idealism uh
so you could like go you know [ __ ] victa
shaolin hegel shelling some more uh
schopenhauer is an
offshoot right or you could just you
know read other
other important thinkers like i mean
mill is reacting to kant
uh and trying to introduce a new kind of
empiricism
or reinforced empiricism there were
there were actually some empiricist
critics of kant that were
uh contemporaries um
[Music]
you know it's really up to you uh i mean
you could read the pragmatists you can
read
um you can read you know if you want to
read idealist you could also read
coleridge and then the american
transcendentalists
who are are playing off account
there's no like one single curriculum
that you you need to follow all right
williams says i've heard a reading of
hobbes where his belief in cooperation
as well as clear goods negates the idea
that he has a he's a moral relativist of
sorts
i'd love to hear your take on this well
it's pretty clear
in the early parts of leviathan that
that hobbes
thinks that he's not a moral relativist
saying that everything is totally
relative to cultures but
he does clearly think that um
some things that we take to be
good in a substantive sense are good
because they're good
for somebody and so there is a kind of
moral relativism there
fortunately he thinks that human nature
is pretty similar across the board
so that kind of gets you out of that and
and you know you've got these laws of
nature right
that that we can deduce provided our
faculties aren't aren't too damaged or
we're not like
deluded by our our own vanity or
something like that
and that provides a kind of basis
for us to to use right so
he does want to derive a genuine you
know
what some people would like to call an
objective morality
in leviathan and he takes himself as
doing that but he is doing that from a
basis that starts out with something
that
that looks a lot like moral relativism
in book one
um as a matter of fact it's kind of an
interesting side point
so hobbs says that he's doing the very
first scientific philosophy
and and specifically social and
political philosophy
and he thinks that the sovereign
needs to get rid of books of previous
philosophy because they're just going to
mess people up they provide people with
pretext
for all their other crazy you know
factionalizing theories
and he includes among them getting rid
of plato aristotle
cicero you know all these all these
ancient thinkers who are
liable to lead to problems and that's
one way of dealing with a
problem of it's not relativism as such
but it's people
able to like have different moral
perspectives
you just drown all the other ones out
and say you can't read them anymore or
teach them
he fortunately he was totally
unsuccessful in getting the sovereign of
the time to
to buy into any of those those ideas
but he was proposing that so yeah
all right um let's see here
milla says since you and seem to enjoy
many christian philosophers i was
wondering if you'd ever be willing to
make videos on spinoza well spinoza
isn't a christian philosopher so that's
not really relevant
um and i've said many times yeah i mean
i make videos
basically for the time being on the
classes that i'm teaching and i don't
teach spinoza very often
but if anybody wants to commission me to
shoot videos on spinoza that means they
pay for
me to do the work and take time away
from all my other projects
i'm perfectly willing to do that so far
nobody's been
interested in ponying up but i do get a
lot of people
asking when are you going to do videos
about spinoza
and you know usually the answer is not
anytime soon unless i'm
unless i'm commissioned um i'm just
there's so many other people that i'm
interested in and want to teach
all right uh let's see here
jim guy are you by any chance familiar
with the works of mock sterner yep i
i am familiar with them i've even like
done tutorials on them
so nominus did plato through the mouth
of socrates
argue that human beings are inevitably
compelled to strive after the good
will this make him a psychological
egoist so i can answer the second
question
right off the bat no i mean there's
nothing about
striving for the good or having a desire
for the good that
makes you a psychological egoist um
[Music]
you could be a dan you know you could be
committed to some sort of deontology
um if you're saying if you add to it the
good
for you the good that that satisfies
your interest then then you could get
something like that but that's not what
ancient virtue ethics does
um and did plato through socrates argue
that human beings are
inevitably compelled to strive after the
good
um i'm trying to think of i mean there's
places where he says like nobody
willingly does things that are bad for
them
although he also brings up people
willingly doing
things that are bad for them in other
places
um and and so you know for socrates it's
a mafia certain
ignorance that leads people to do things
that are contrary to their
their true interests or or you know
what's really good for them
to prefer say the pleasant to the just
or you know
things along those lines um
that's usually where the conversation
lies it's less in oh you're really just
trying to satisfy
something for your own desires deep down
inside
because you can have screwed up desires
i mean if you're
if you're addicted to something you're
you're trying to satisfy a desire that
you have but it's a desire that's
actually harmful for you
so all right um
jake in one of your language videos you
said mandarin arabic and spanish for
today are the most important to learn
my question is why those well i mean
i you might want to look at how many
people speak those
and how many people here are able to
to translate those sorts of things so
mandarin that's that's a no-brainer
isn't it i mean
if you can speak mandarin uh and you
know
recognize enough characters you can
engage with
the largest nation on earth which has
all sorts of other uh representatives of
its culture
all over the world so that's that one's
kind of a non-brain you know no brainer
they're going to pass us up as the
largest economy within this this coming
decade the projections say
um spanish similar
reason you know i mean think about all
the places you can go if you speak
spanish
most of central and south america
granted
portuguese is useful in brazil too right
so those those two are pretty
straightforward arabic
you know probably more important when
we're engaged in our endless wars
but still an important language you know
um
how many arab speakers are there in the
world wouldn't it be nice to be able to
read literature in arabic
we could also add other you know major
world languages to the list
russian is good to have hindi's good to
have
portuguese is good to have because of
brazil and also mozambique at angola
right
and portugal which is beautiful place to
go um
so you know the reason i think i was
probably
bringing that up is because most places
will have spanish as an
offering and then they'll have like
latin french or
german and it's cool to speak french
it's cool to speak
german but um they're not as useful as
speaking mandarin you know or or spanish
um so yeah
that's probably enough about that
you want to think about like where
things are going in the future
waste your opinion on the problem of
universals i don't really have an
opinion on the problem of universals
usually when people ask me about these
big abstract things
i don't i don't have that much to say
about them quite frankly
um let's see here
jabber cash says i'm writing a paper
defending g
moore's proof of the external world
namely here's a hand here's another
i'm faced with the realization that
skepticism is just a black huge black
hole from which nothing can't escape
i guess it depends on what kind of
skepticism you have in mind right
um you know somebody who i do a good bit
of work on besides descartes who i
really like
is is david hume i teach him pretty
frequently in classes
and you know hume is a skeptic right but
a skeptic
of a certain sort he doesn't think that
our
our the skepticism that he takes to be
you know quite quite
true and in some respects helpful
translates well into the outside world
you know you've got your filth
philosopher's study
and then you go and play some pool with
your buddies uh
and all those skeptical thoughts kind of
disappear
cicero himself belonged to the the
academic school
of philosophy so it's possible to have a
sort of skepticism that is not like the
oh nobody knows anything you know uh we
can't
we can't take any positions like
pyronian skepticism
we don't have to vanish into that that
that is kind of a black hole
um but i think it's possible to have
have forms of skepticism that are
more mitigated than that
all right um andrew says i keep coming
back to philosophy every quarter
i forget for months but i'm trying to
practice philosophy
struggling to keep up with it daily any
any advice oh that's that's a great
question
yeah i would say um you know start
small pick something that you could do
every day
like it could be a reading regimen like
you know a great example i wish i could
walk off and come back but
i don't want to do that i i've got um
seneca's letters right and there's a
couple of different editions of them
uh there's the goomer edition there's
the one that's uh
more recent by um long and graver
um and you know i like to every day
read a letter by seneca
um just to like keep working my way
through it and
you know i go through the book um
basically like twice a year
doing that and there's more there's
more there's more days than there are
two courses of the letters but but it's
still you know um
a good practice and you could do that
with like you know nietzsche's
the smoke zarathustra you could do that
with a lot of
um a lot of works
where it's divided into two bits
actually i've got epictetus over here so
like you could do
epictetus's um uh discourses and just
read one
chapter each each day some chapters are
longer than others
so you could have a reading practice you
could also have a
like check if you're trying to do
practices coming from philosophy you
could have like a check in with yourself
each night
um that's something that the stoics do
christians pick that up is the
examination of conscience
put to somewhat different purposes you
could also like
set aside a certain time of the day for
for doing something uh philosophical
right i think that that those are things
that you could do that where you make it
like a
a regular thing and then just build off
of that
so
stephen warren i've just picked up uh
geeda boards the society of the
spectacle
and i find many parts to be totally
incomprehensible
if you have any exposure to this work
what advice would you give
i do have some exposure to the work in
part because
my my wife um
went to european graduate school and
they loved that text there
even more than they love heidegger and
i've always thought it's kind of
overrated
but people love to use it and i think it
is because of
its ambiguity like you can you can turn
it into so many
there's this expression a wax nose if
you've ever heard that
so it can be turned this way it can be
turned this way
and when you've got these these uh very
rich continental texts you can almost
make anything you like out of them
and so um i will say this
it's been a while since i've looked at
it i don't find myself referring back to
it so
i can't think it made much impression on
me uh
by by opposition to like you know
reading people like bataille
or you know um maurice mariloponti
or you know even marshall mcluhan right
so i i don't know if you need to to to
read it or not
you could you could think about it this
way with any given text
you can always ask yourself there's
other texts i could be reading
and making progress with is it worth it
digging into this text and a lot of our
decisions about that
are based on a kind of testimony right
we're like well
so and so whose opinion i respect says
that there's something
here so i better keep plowing away at it
but it could be that so
and so whose opinion you respect maybe
maybe you don't respect their opinion
later down the line you know and you're
like oh they were full of crap
i i don't have to worry about reading
this person because they said we had to
do that right
all right utah has a question that i i
don't have any answer for
how different would our society be if
everyone were a centaur
i think we'd be screwed because we have
all these
all these buildings that are set up for
for human beings
not for you know human horse hybrids i
mean i think about how the hell would i
get out of this apartment
we're fortunate we're in a loft right so
there's high ceilings
um but what if my ceiling was eight feet
high i'd have to be like stooped over
all the time and getting through the
doorway could be tricky
and then going down the hall and getting
in the elevator right
man we we would just be we'd be screwed
if we suddenly
transformed our bodies into different
bodies that way
so uh day waste comments toilets would
be quite different
[Music]
i don't know if we'd have them right uh
all right watch it oh it just skipped a
little bit
so let me find where we were
um all right jimmy d
what do you think about the presidential
election results well i'm happy that
trump is
on his way out hopefully provided he
doesn't do any crazy nonsense
although it seems like the secret
service and the military are already you
know
like moving the way that they ought to
uh to have an orderly transition of
power
i'm glad there was you know much less
election violence than we were worried
about
coming from largely the right wing um
and we have to deal with the fact that
we we do have a country of
many many people who were went all
in on the trump uh agenda
and um you know i'm a political
independent but i voted straight
democrat this time around
in part because you know the trump
administration
to me is is done so much stuff across
the line
so much stuff that's that's clearly bad
the
senate republicans as well um i think as
a virtue ethicist there's no way you can
possibly support
that administration or that party
it's not to say that the democrats are
great but
they certainly were the lesser of two
evils in this case
and our our local republican party
is really terrible our wisconsin
republican party they are largely
responsible for kovid being out of
control here in
in wisconsin um and so
you know we've got some real challenges
ahead we we can say well
thank god we're not gonna have another
four years of that
garbage and nonsense and we'll slow our
you know
what the slide that we were on into you
know fascism and cruelty and white
supremacy but
the seeds fruit are still out there and
we have a lot of work ahead and biden
uh and harris are basically just
centrist candidates
not neither of them are for some things
that are really going to have to be the
case
if we're going to continue on as a
viable country we need a national health
care system
that's all there is to it what we have
right now is not working for
for so many people in so many different
ways we could do a whole talk about that
and we're gonna have to put a lot of
pressure
those of us who are interested in this
sort of thing we're gonna have to put a
lot of pressure on the biden
administration
and on our local representatives to
start doing the right thing more
more frequently so yeah
all right um antagaya asked what's my
favorite alan moore graphic novel i
don't really read graphic novels
so i don't i don't have one uh kay says
drinking a gross swing top currently i
like gross that's that's
a good beer that's a good that's an
example of a good pilsner right
um saint paulie girl too is a good
pilsner
all right uh jesse says you've made
those great videos about phases and your
philosophical thinking do you now
older anticipate any more big changes in
your philosophical and or religious
beliefs
um i don't know i mean
there could be some uh you know i'm
hoping that i'll probably
find some other thinkers and movements
that i'll be like oh man this is great
stuff
i got to figure out no i'm not going to
have like a phaser i'm like now i'm a
something ite or something ian
right but it'll be more like oh i got so
much to learn from
from this person or this movement over
here let's incorporate it into the stuff
that i'm already
heavily focused on like aristotelianism
and platonism and stoicism
and you know existential philosophy and
dialectical philosophy how can we
how can we bring this stuff in right so
i do
i do still um keep running into things i
mean i think that
my career going forward
is going to be uh probably
more and more oriented towards doing
philosophy
in in practical and public ways that can
inform professional life
and unless abstract i mean i i'm always
going to be
rooted in the history of philosophy and
shoot you know
i'll keep shooting videos uh so long as
youtube
exists or other media exists for that
because people find find them helpful
and i'll keep making podcast episodes
but um
i don't know that there's going to be
any any big phases ahead i think i'm
kind of
in my i found stuff that works for me
kind of groove
you know
matt asks i'm trying to understand the
transcendental deduction would you
breathe
mind briefly explaining the empirical
unity of at perception and how this
presupposes the transcendental
unity of that perception yeah briefly
explaining that
um i'm going to say pass except i'll
just say this right
so kant thinks that we we have to have
some way of explaining how it is that we
we understand not not understand how we
perceive things
and we perceive them not just as a
gobbly [ __ ] of all sorts of crazy crap
but you know connected together and so
that's part of
that's part of what's going on in the
first critique
but i'm not going to try to like pull
stuff out of my head
to come up with a pithy explanation
right here so
uh alternative what is the best piece of
advice you'd give to somebody in their
20s
um yeah that's that's that's a good
question
because you know there people have like
what would you say to your 20 year old
self so my 20 year old self was in the
1990s when when work was easier to find
when um you know student loans were
becoming a problem but weren't
remotely the problem that they are today
when our politics was polarized but we
still had a functioning
democracy uh in in many respects at
least it wasn't ideal but it was a hell
of a lot better than it was
than it is now um
yeah what would i say to somebody in
their 20s now
prepare for a long hard ride because
things are are at crisis points
and the people who
are in charge are often not making good
decisions that's not
something new but you have to find ways
to get your
get your voices heard and there is there
is also a tendency to say oh man things
are so screwed up screw it
i'm just gonna like withdraw into some
sort of
escapism like fandom of some sort
or um some you know some ineffective
guaranteed ineffective political program
or you know some some playing around
with religions but never really you know
fully committing to anything
avoid those things those are those are
gonna suck up time
and lead you into blind alleys there's
so much good stuff
out there that you can be trying to
incorporate into your life and building
upon and studying
that you you really should try to focus
on those and
the other thing is um you know i see
this with a lot of my students they they
don't have enough of a frame of
reference
yet to fully know um
how to make what to make of their
situation that they're currently in
and so they they get dismayed and they
feel like well if i can't fix
things totally there's no point in it
the good that you can do within your
community
within your family within the structure
of your relationships even if it
even if like you do work and it's almost
like a sisyphean task you push the
boulder up the hill
comes down the other side it is still a
good so if you have a
conversation with somebody that
leads them to one more truth in their
life
even if they forget it tomorrow you did
something good
and so you know make sure you don't
downplay those things because otherwise
it's pretty easy to get discouraged i
think
you know
all right jim asks how familiar are you
with the director charlie kaufman
not at all i mean i i don't know many
directors i don't i don't pay very close
attention to that
so i may have seen some of his stuff but
i don't know
i don't know him by name bad bite
if the world ended you could only save
10 philosophy books from total
destruction which 10 books would you
save for the post-apocalyptic world
that's a good question um that actually
might be a good video because
you know you wouldn't necessarily pick
the best books for yourself like you
know i did that video
10 philosophical books i'd bring to a to
a desert island
you'd want stuff that because you want
to think about succession planning
you want stuff where people can
understand it without it requiring
reference to a whole world of other
books
and um where somebody other than
yourself
could read it and make sense of it
because you could die right you could
gather these
10 books together and like you're
hanging out in the fallout shelter
and there's all these young people and
you're like you're gonna have to you
know
continue the civilization fortunately i
saved these 10 books oops now i i'm
poisoned and i die right
um and then they look at the books and
they're like what the hell is this crap
i don't know
i don't know what this is right um so i
don't know
you'd have to have books that are pretty
pretty straightforward
pretty clear and touch
on central things of the human
conditions i'd probably like avoid big
metaphysics and epistemology stuff
i mean almost nothing from continental
or analytic philosophy useful at all
pretty much nothing that kant wrote
would be useful
david hume wouldn't be that readable to
the average reader
so i don't know that's a tough one i can
give you some general
um general characteristics but
um other than that not too much right
uh fact totem i loved your video about
kafka's penal colony do you plan to more
make more videos about philosophy and
literature would like to hear your take
on eta hoffman's sandman i don't know
eta hoffman
um yeah i mean i've made plenty of other
things about
uh philosophy and literature thus books
are thus
literary work uh i also just did some
stuff recently on
on brothers karamazov right and i've
done some stuff on
the underground man and and um
so yeah i'll i'll keep doing things
ursula kayla green's
the ones who walk away from homeless
i actually do like a whole series on
called worlds of speculative fiction
that is about philosophical themes
in in sci-fi horror
alternate history fantasy been doing
that for about five years now
um so yeah i'll be making more
more videos about philosophy and
literature um like i've said before
the bulk of what i'm shooting especially
in the core concepts
is for my classes it is to
to satisfy the needs of my students who
are
taking my classes and then everybody
else gets to come along for the ride so
this this semester i had the time to
shoot three videos on kafka's
in the penal colony something i've been
wanting to do for a while but
i didn't have time to shoot on
metamorphosis or or the trial or
the other ones that i wanted to do um
the trial actually that's that's if i'm
going to do another kafka thing
that's the one i want to focus on next
but um you know i've got some others
down the line
that i'll be doing um
i will be doing in other worlds of
speculative fiction on ursula k leguins
earthsea
novels on the last three of them
uh later on this month a couple
saturdays from now
so you might want to tune into that
um
rima says i was wondering about what you
thought about carly josper's and where
you'd suggest to start on him
that's a good question i don't read
jasper's very much anymore i read him a
lot as an undergraduate
and i never found him as interesting as
the other existentialists and
sometimes it's kind of a matter of taste
i do remember going to the carl josper's
society and this this is kind of an
experience that i probably shouldn't
have drawn too much from but
i was at society for phenomenological
and existential philosophy
and i saw on the program that there was
a carl josper society and i was like
i'll go check that out you know
and it turned out to be five old people
who basically were like a carl josper's
admiration
society and just chatting back and forth
and they were they were happy as hell
that i was there because like young
blood
and i was like this is the caliber of
people who are
studying jaspers but then i you know i
reflected and i was like well
you know philosophers kind of come in
and they go out um
i shouldn't draw too many conclusions
from this jaspers is probably better
than his current followers
all of them by now would probably be
dead you know they were so
so old um i i would say like you know
you could look at uh what is that book
the uh
um i think it would be called the
spiritual
situation of time do you guys to get it
right um that might be a good one to
start with
i mean he's an interesting guy i i
shouldn't knock him
i haven't looked at his works for quite
a while so
i keep meaning to go back and see what's
there um
re-reading existentialists in my 40s and
now
50s i see a lot of stuff there that i
missed when i read them in my teens and
20s
so maybe there's a lot more there all
right uh
lokesh i have a very general question
what do you think of technology and its
effect on society
well i think technology's been around
basically since we've been human
aristotle talks about it i don't think
there's anything general to say about
technology and its effect
on society because it's it's one of
those questions that's too
too general right it's too too high
level you've got to ask about what
different kinds of technology and what
they do and how they transform society
but you don't
really have society without technology
right language is a technology
um you can't you can't have a
functioning society without
some basic things you know you don't
necessarily have to have the wheel
but it sure helps and you know you don't
necessarily have to have agriculture but
it sure helps to get to a certain level
masonry carpentry all these sorts of
things
we can also think about our relations
with animals as ways in which we've
turned them into technology you know
dogs are guarding technology
cats are mice eating technology
as a matter of fact the latin word for
cat besides
katus is moosa caps mouse catcher
so i i don't know that you can really
say that much about about
um technology and society at that level
of generality
kaido says do you have much interest in
aesthetics if so what is your take on it
i don't have a take
on aesthetics i have an interest in it
it's
not an area it's always an area that i
feel kind of like
i'm an intruder or interloper i do
really need to to and i've taken courses
in aesthetics but i do really need to
like buckle down and eventually
do some of the the reading that i
haven't done
and put together an aesthetics class
because i am teaching at milwaukee
institute of art and design
and you know it's artists and designers
and they don't have a philosophical
aesthetics class and i'm the resident
philosopher
so i really want to get my proverbial
crap together and and
put in the time to like go back to some
text that i haven't looked at
since i took an aesthetics class back in
grad school or other texts that i know
are important
and put together a curriculum but i but
i feel
you know much more of like an ethics and
personal development
and maybe you could say in a certain
respect metaphysics
and social and political philosophy kind
of kind of person so
you can't do everything you know all
right uh
bat bite says i'm a dane do you
recommend georg brown days
it's not very popular outside of
literature um
i mean recommend if you want to if you
want to understand something about like
early existentialism yeah i guess so i
mean i haven't read much of what he said
it's mostly just been letters um he is
the guy who
identified uh to nietzsche that
dostoevsky was doing something similar
and recommended that he should read
dostoevsky
did that and said oh yeah you're right
so you know there's
clearly something there i don't even
know what's available in translation
that that's kind of a good question and
if it's not available in translation
then we get somebody who reads danish to
do the translation work and that's
that's
kind of a smaller circle compared to
german or or french
or even italian and it can be a hard
sell
you know um but maybe maybe there's
plenty of stuff available i don't really
know
uh stacy says um
food shortage is the latest issue coming
out of the land
administration um
guests yeah i mean there are there are
issues that we've been struggling with
for a long time like food deserts and
our food system you know covet is
covered could have gone way worse in
terms of the food
system um but there are some sort of
knock-on effects think about how
meat packing plants here like in green
bay
um were particularly bad places for
spreading kobe that's why that county is
is a hotbed of covid here
uh the jovis if mcintyre is right in the
philosophical divide falls along
nietzsche and aristotle which is not
what he actually says
what do you think is the most convincing
argument against nietzsche
i don't think there's a most convincing
argument i think that you put forward
arguments
but mcintyre doesn't say it's between
nietzsche and aristotle he's saying that
these are two sort of like paths that we
can take in our general situation
that it's not like people have nature on
one side or aristotle on the other it's
more like a
fundamentally nichian approach in
certain respects
and a fundamentally aristotelian
approach in certain respects that would
include
others as well so i mean
i guess you could say do you want to
develop as a human being
and have communities that actually
function and provide possibilities of
adjudicating moral
issues then you want the aristotelian
path
i mean you could you could pick all
sorts of other stuff and it would be
that other path
right so
let's look at the next one uh
lenny penny what are some other
philosophers or authors you recommend
for someone that really likes nietzsche
okay um
i mean you could talk about philosophers
who
use need and incorporate
ideas from him there you've got a whole
ton of people
i mean foucault talks about how
nietzsche
you know provided something that that
the
the french academy which was mostly
interested in like structuralism
existentialism
and marxism at the time just just
couldn't provide
i think duluz has a kind of similar view
on nietzsche as well
you could say batai might as well well
he's a little bit earlier right
um i think mark schaeler is a great
person to read he's got a wonderful
little book on rizontomont
where he takes nietzsche's concept and
he says here's what he got right here's
what he got wrong
let's let's take this this concept and
make it work jaspers who were talking
about earlier obviously very influenced
by nietzsche heidegger thought that
nietzsche was so
important nietzsche is the last
metaphysician to heidegger
that he devoted four volumes worth of
lectures to nietzsche and they're
pretty good to read you know um
so there's there's tons and tons of
people out there who are
influenced by nietzsche uh or
incorporating his works
in one way or another um
i would avoid the people who try to
defang nietzsche
who try to make him into just a defender
of rhetoric
or you know he didn't really mean all
that stuff about races
and you know the uber match and all that
i think he was committed to that stuff
right doesn't mean that we have to be
any more than we have to buy into the
eternal recurrence of the same which
to me seems pretty tangential um
although i seem to be in the minority of
nature interpreters on that matter
um but you know you really want to you
want to find the people who take him
seriously and get something
out of his work nietzsche is sort of
like playing with dynamite you know
in some respects um
all right let's see here
[Music]
dean do you have any tips on practicing
or applying philosophy
in life um yeah
again keep your expectations low at
first
so i've been talking about this because
last month it was all sorts of stoic
stuff right
one of the biggest one of the two
biggest mistakes that stoics make
right uh when they're first starting out
and epictetus counsels you against this
in
in the end caribbean is like getting
into any intentional form of life
oh man i'm doing this new thing now and
it's so cool
it's called stoicism and it's like oh
there's all these insights
and it's going to change my life for
good forever right
well no not no more than like doing some
some crazy diet
is going to you it's something that you
got to get a plow through
and build upon and do in kind of a
progressive way
the other thing is don't expect everyone
else to like buy into
whatever it is that you think stoicism
is so you're like
hey man don't take you know don't take
it personally when i'm a jerk to you
you should be more stoic it's not stoic
to expect other people to be stoic
and you can say the same thing about any
other philosophy of life if you want to
become an existentialist and be like
oh wow i really am responsible for my
choices
and there is this open field ahead of me
there's no like preconceived destiny
that doesn't mean that your neighbor
buys into that stuff so
you got to like work on your own stuff
and don't worry so much about convincing
other people
about the rightness of the viewpoint
show them that the viewpoint is right um
by how you
make it part of your life again
epictetus advice for stoicism right
show show us your shoulders he says
don't show us your weights so um
so i i think that could be useful tips
right there
um bruno asked do you have any brazilian
philosophers interest
i don't actually know that many
brazilian philosophers in the sense of
knowing their works i mean i know a few
people
doing philosophy in brazil we've
actually published some of them
in stoicism today like aldo bennucci
uh but and i routinely meet people from
brazil it seems that the aristotle and
aristotelian
tradition conference here at marquette
university in milwaukee
when they hold it i'm not quite sure why
there must be some pipeline connection
um i mean i i read pedagogy the
oppressed by free
you know freire but um that's been a
while so i can't say that it's an area
that i actually know that much about i
probably
should um it'd be a good excuse for
learning portuguese which is something
i've always wanted to do because
i love the portuguese language even
though i know so little of it
and i still do have you know uh kamosh
on my on my shelf
waiting to be read i've read it in
translation but but i haven't
read uh in portuguese
other than looking at like pages and be
reading it to myself and being like well
this sounds really cool but i can't
figure out what's being said so i should
probably
do that but when am i going to find the
time right
um all right uh
samuel asks hello in the university
where i study in finland wittgenstein is
a big influence
uh i can see why such a great thinker
are you familiar with his work
i actually did a lot of work on
wittgenstein
when i was younger i went through an
entire i did a video on this vidcon
shiny and faze
and i came to the conclusion that he
wasn't really a great thinker after all
he was an
interesting thinker but that he would
have
gotten a lot more mileage out of
philosophy had he had been better read
and you know i think the mystique
surrounding him
is is really what what elevated him and
you know
i got to study with somebody who was two
generations removed from wittgenstein
she had studied she was like an
up-and-coming wittgenstein scholar until
unfortunately she died young of cancer
and she had studied with people who
studied with wittgenstein and and it was
kind of a mixed bag
you know i mean i i like reading that
kenshine i like teaching him
but um i gotta say i think
in retrospect he's been overrated a lot
of the interesting stuff you can find in
other philosophers of language being
done at the same time
without all of the philosophies therapy
commitments
um that said you know there's no reason
not to read them
he's still worth reading and puttering
around with you know
so all right uh
maria can altruism be egoistic i think
bacon and another philosopher the
time had a disagreement about that it
depends on how you define altruism and
egoism
i mean if you define altruism as the
opposite of egoism
nope right if you if you like
say peter singer he's got an entire
article on reciprocal altruism
and how it connects up with egoism yep
you know it really depends on
whose version of it so you got to get
away from that general
level of generality of you know is is is
this compatible with this you've got to
say who's
whose viewpoint or whose version of it
um
chelsea is it important to consider
heidegger's anti-semitism and nazism
reading his ontology
depends on what you mean by his ontology
if you mean his uh
fundamental ontology and and being
being in time no not really i mean
there's there's places where you're like
oh see how he
went that way you know with his
understanding
for example of tradition or the crowd
that they right
um or things along those lines you can
say ah yeah yeah i see
i see the nazi writing on the wall
um there's definitely some works where
you're like wow this this is total nazi
stuff
right the better address for example or
the black notebooks but i i don't think
that you know
i don't think that his work as a whole
is um particularly affected by it's more
like
he's he's making certain choices
that could go that way but could go
other ways i mean you look at his his
students
you've got a rent gotomer
[Music]
um blanking out his name the guy who
wrote the nestor hans jonas right
they show that you can take heidigarian
uh approaches and ideas
of course they are doing a very original
work of their own
and go different directions with it so
um
and you know if we're thinking about
consider hit consider his stuff reading
his ontology
um it's gonna be like oh we're not gonna
read this guy because he's a nazi
i mean give it long enough you can find
reasons not to read anybody
you know that that i've i think has kind
of played out
um but you know you do want to be
cognizant of the fact that um
in some respects was he was he a nazi
because he really loved nazism or was he
a nazi because
he had some other mistaken ideas that
made him susceptible
to that i mean it's sort of like so this
is coming to mind right now
this is something i've talked about in
the past is recent election with
trumpism
and and you know the metastatizing of
the tea party
and some other unsavory forces within
american politics
i've seen so many colleagues and
family members and friends who are for
example conservative catholics
who are really interested in the
abortion issue
and we're not you know we're not really
that interested in the republican party
and all the other stuff that they stood
for
eventually start to buy in here and
there and there because once you're like
having the conversations and part of the
community and thinking well we're
aligned with each other against those
bad guys over there the left
um on these things on this one issue it
becomes a lot easier
to start swallowing a lot of other pills
i think heidegger effectively
did that with the nazism you know i
don't think that there's anything in his
works
had the nazi party not existed that
would have steered him
into some some very not national
socialism or fascism or integral
nationalism
or any of the other similar isms out
there at the time
um but it was there
and then he slide into that right
all right uh
jeff webber what are your thoughts on
philosophical degrees expanding to
arabic chinese and indian philosophy
do the current programs do a disservice
to philosophy you got to say which
current programs
i mean at marquette we have the aquinas
and arabs project
so lots of graduate students studying
arabic at marquette
now our cat's in trouble right because
they're going to be cutting probably
about 450 staff
and faculty positions because they've
mismanaged their money
uh that's an administrative issue but
there's plenty of places that are that
are doing it and then there's plenty of
places that aren't so you gotta
you gotta say which ones you've got in
mind you know
you can't generalize about the american
university system because there isn't
any such thing right
you can't generalize about the american
philosophical
scene because it's pretty fragmented
there's a lot of different things going
on
so you know what are my thoughts about
expanding to arabic chinese and indian
philosophy
um i think it's great when we can do
that i also think that we don't have to
like
get into silly stuff about oh you know
the canon by itself is
totally racist and we we have to stop
reading aristotle aristotle's cancelled
i think that's stupid [ __ ]
right frankly um and you know i think we
can also continue reading
david hume and emanuel kant even though
they are racists
and say uh does the you know we can
study the philosophy and then we can
like look at
anthropology from a pragmatic point of
view and say wow this is some pretty
hardcore racism
that doesn't mean we earn the books or
anything and i think it's great when we
do comparative philosophy when we say
all right we're going to do virtue
ethics
let's do real virtue ethics and see what
the confucians have to say and see
what's going on in indian philosophy and
see what er
what arabic commentators and also jewish
commentators
and also you know other it's not just
arabic philosophy right
the muslim world what what they have to
say about the aristocracy and tradition
and bring in others as well the stoics
also have a virtue ethics tradition as
a long as argued uh quite persuasively
and um so i think it's great the problem
is
you know we only have so much time to
teach we're kind of
we're we're stuck in these 15-week
semesters we're off
actually 12-week semesters uh when you
take up
you put in all the breaks and stuff like
that that we
we have um
so you know like i can smuggle in some
mentions as i'm doing
in some of my classes but you know we
the other
issue is too i'm i'm more confident
teaching ancient greek philosophy
because i can read classical greek
if i'm teaching you know the analects or
the mencius
or other works in chinese philosophy i'm
dependent on the translator
much more than i am uh when i can go
back to the original and so i think a
lot of people
you know who are used to teaching out of
their scholarship are a little bit leery
in that way but
that that's a you know a sign that we
probably should have more learning of
chinese and
sanskrit and arabic and stuff like that
uh james uh oops there it skipped a bit
let me
find that and get back to james just
asking something about
uh animal ethics here we go have you
read much on animal ethics
if you have are there any writers you
would recommend is it a topic that
interests you
i've not done a lot of reading on it i
mean most of the stuff that i'm
connected
with in that respect other than like you
know reading peter singer of course
who you should read is in terms of the
food system
um and with with those conversations
it's more like
my wife is engaged with people through
her connections with you know
the food business school and you know
the milwaukee food school
and all these other culinary things
there's a lot of conversations going on
about
factory farming and um
agriculture and things like that so so i
i get into some of those discussions but
i'm not really an expert on it
i am intending eventually to write a
book about
the ethics of making end-of-life
decisions
and care decisions for for pets because
again something that i've seen a lot of
people go through
um really agonizing about that i thought
it could be good to write a book
about that and that's going to require a
lot of research on my part i'm going to
have to do
you know interviews with vets and vet
techs and
other people and see what whether
anything's actually been
written about that so all right um
let's see here ben says what do you
think about holding ethical
theory principles in theory but not in
practice
i agree with the conscient principle of
not lying but i probably wouldn't act on
it does this invalidate the theory no it
just means that you're not consistent
right i don't know why you'd want to
hold
principles only in theory and not in
practice
it's not really holding principles in
that case
but no it doesn't invalidate the theory
it just means that you're not a ideal
exemplar of the theory right
all right um jeff sullivan have you read
abelard any thoughts
uh yeah i've i've read some amalarth
he's an interesting guy he has some
worthwhile things to say he's somebody
who i never teach because i never have
the time to actually get get that much
into the medievals usually when i'm
doing
medievals it's one of four people
augustine boethius anselm or or aquinas
and
i i usually have to pick which of these
two am i going to get to teach
because i don't get to teach classes
just on medieval philosophy
i also um do teach sometimes his letters
between him
and elise uh where he really comes out
as kind of a kind of an [ __ ]
quite frankly
so you know he's somebody i like
uh an animal specialist the way i am
with a handsome
but he's certainly somebody worth worth
checking out
um let's see here
jeff weber the u.s army has invested a
lot in the master resiliency program to
try to short issues in the ranks have
you seen
this program do you think philosophy
stoic thought could help they view stock
thought
donald robertson is connected with that
that sort of thing so you want to you
want to pay more attention to him
i'm i'm not particularly involved in it
um i think that stoic philosophy can
help provided they don't screw it up and
reduce it to something that it isn't
nancy sherman was writing about this you
know over a decade
ago in stoic warriors um so you know
there's a lot of interest in that sort
of thing but it's important to get it
right
tyson woolman have you read any of
robert brandom's work i've not only read
robert brandon's work i actually saw him
speak here at marquette
last year for the when he accepted the
aquinas medal
or was that two years ago um
so yeah i've i've read brandon he's an
interesting guy
i like him because he's a good historian
and that makes him less of an analytic
he's an analytic who got so much into
the history of stuff that he actually
became a
pretty decent you know historian of
philosophy so
all right um can't read hebrew so i
can't i can't
say this person's name what do i think
about giovanni gentile
haven't read them so not much to say
about it
ben cloak when's the next half hour
hegel if you're asking about the videos
i'm hopefully going to shoot some this
month
now that as i was mentioning at the
start this has been a very busy
october with stoic everything
you know the election stuff midterms and
classes
and some illnesses so i haven't i
haven't had the time but
this this month i should be able to
shoot some
uh jake what are a couple of the core
problems in analytic philosophy where do
you think analytic philosophy is going
so i don't know you should ask an
analytic what what the core
problems are i would say somebody from
the outside we're now in a time
where analytics will even talk about
this being a post-analytic phase
you've got all these different projects
going on most of the people are not
communicating
with each other there's no there's no
internal like
consistency across analytic philosophy
it's now just become kind of like a
style
and and most of them don't know their
own history you know they don't read the
the people who
led up to whatever discourse they're
they're reading in the most recent five
articles um
so you know it's not going to die out
but it's and sometimes it can actually
make some good contributions
um but it's it's also
a lot of like taking up space that could
be devoted to
more interesting projects i'd say
um even i'm wondering if you have any
advice for an
aspiring philosophy youtuber writer i
admire how you go through hegel and
others with a lot of rigor
i wonder how you go undaunted into it
well
i mean i've been reading hegel now for
25 years right so that helps
it's sort of like asking somebody who
lays bricks
you know man how how are you able to lay
those bricks so so
you know easily not think about it hell
i've been doing it since i was 16.
they could say um so that that's part of
it
uh part of it i guess you know
when i first started getting into it to
talk about the daunting
part i was a little bit worried you know
um i have to give my wife a lot of
credit
she was the one who first encouraged me
to
um shoot youtube videos and
at first i was just like plunking down a
camera in the classroom
and she said what's the worst that could
happen and i was like yeah actually that
that's quite right
and i was i was the the naysayer i was
like who's gonna want to watch me i'm a
nobody
you know i'm not at some fancy school at
that time i was teaching at a
small historically black college
fayetteville state university right
um and uh you know
not not all that well known but as it
turned out um
people liked the content that i had to
do and and as time went on i got better
at it you know i made
some kind of dumb mistakes at the start
um but you know as you do it you get
more and more used to it like i shot
three videos from my
biomedical ethics class this morning on
stuff in a textbook that's
sitting behind me right over there
that you know i don't find particularly
super compelling but
it's it's it's an it's worth doing some
videos on
i guess part of what you'd have to do is
like find what you
what what do you think you could shoot
100 videos on well and not like just
what are you competent to do because the
competency can come with studying right
but what do you care enough about to
to invest that time in right um
if you don't if you're not really into
descartes don't shoot videos on
descartes
um if you don't think that it you know
that hegel has that much to offer don't
don't try to shoot videos on hegel um
[Music]
so you know pick stuff that you you
actually care about i would say
um all right
ken blackwell have you read any novels
by
shishan liu
i find them interesting as they focus
more on the societal challenges of
science fiction
so i have uh the first in that trilogy
on my shelf because somebody bought it
for me for my birthday after the big
birthday bash
i've read some of his short stories and
it's it's great stuff and i'm looking
forward to
to reading more um
the dart is it the yeah the dark forest
right no the three body problem is the
star
the the start of that trilogy so i've
got the three body
problem hoping to read it over christmas
break because i'm hoping to talk about
it next
next year in the worlds of speculative
fiction so
all right um let's see here
raid what do i think of the claim that
nietzsche is a proto-fascist
uh you know got to define proto-fascist
he's not a proto-fascist in the way that
charlemagne
is uh the founder of accion francaise
where
he's the father of what we call integral
nationalism
nowadays uh you know regimes like franco
spain
and salazars portugal get classified as
as fascists but they were really
integral nationalists
um and and so you know there you got a
real proto-fascist that's why ernst
nolte
has that that book where he does a
little bit of you know uh
there's there's a little bit of fast and
loose stuff there but he says you know
oxy on frances italian fascism
national socialism these are all forms
of a certain kind of totalitarianism
um and there's there's affinities
between them i think that's that's right
is nietzsche a proto-fascist i mean
there's some
important bits of fascism that are kind
of missing there like i mean read
the spoke zarathustra and his
discussions about the state
the state has the new idol doesn't fit
in that well with classical fascism does
it
so it's it's kind of a contested issue
i'd say
um
govind although trump is gone do you
think we'll get rid of trumpism anytime
soon probably not i mean
you can hear horns out there right now
there's there's
it's either the left or the right who
has got
a march going on i don't know which
until i go out and take a look at it
um and no we're not going to get rid of
trumpism
and there's going to be people
idealizing him
and engaging in all sorts of sour puss
you know
oh we were robbed kind of [ __ ] for
for years now and
it's going to be the same people who
were against obama because he was black
and because they bought into narratives
about we're going to
everyone's going to take your guns and
you know some of the worst aspects of
america on the right
fed into trumpism the tea party was sort
of staging ground and trump came along
and metastasized all these things sort
of like some
some disgusting tumor you know and
that's not going away
and there were a lot of people who came
along for the ride and then got screwed
like paul ryan from our state you know
rance priebus
um chris christie's another great
example of somebody who bought in and
got got screwed
and then there's people like mitch
mcconnell and the republicans
in in the senate or our our republicans
here in the wisconsin
legislature um they're
you know some of them are just
opportunists some of them
are using these sorts of things it's not
going away anytime soon
and so we have you know we have a lot of
rough times ahead so yeah but we're
going to be way better off
with him out of office and even a
centrist like
biden in office um even if biden is like
halfway incompetent he's not going to be
95
incompetent and cruel and
crazy you know um so there
there's that um
mega mega z zeke meister says when
studying philosophy
is it better to focus on a particular
thinker school and delve deeply into one
general approach
or is it better to focus on a particular
issue and study different views
i would say it's actually better to
focus on particular thinkers and
schools because you're going to get into
different issues
and you're going to get into other
opposed schools
on those issues i think the topics
approach
you know you don't when you do that
you're only getting the
views that whoever's teaching you thinks
are the important views on it
and you're liable to find out later on
that you missed out on a whole bunch of
stuff so i think
i would go with the the uh thinkers and
movements but you got to jump around too
don't just don't just pick um
you know a particular canon and stick
with that
noah noah noah any good recommendation
for continental philosophy of science
not really my area so now um
[Music]
charles i found ideas pointing at zen
awareness and the moment zone and
heidegger's being in time i'm confused
there's not really anything to be
confused about and it's not particularly
zen it's all sorts of other schools of
buddhism as well
talk about that sort of thing and
you know there were some buddhists who
came to visit heidegger and said i think
there's some connections
in your work and heidegger said okay
it's not surprising to find that that
many great thinkers have similar
thoughts
so yeah um
eric asks what's my view on the works of
foucault do i have any understanding for
understanding to lose in his critique of
psychoanalysis so let's start with the
second one
yeah you got to understand when you're
reading anti-oedipus that it's not
directed at an american context
it's directed at a french context in
which there's a
hardcore psychoanalytic establishment
the same establishment that jacqueline
pushed against but also in some respects
belongs to
and um a lot of a lot of that book is is
targeted at that
and that's an establishment of you know
the 1960s
uh rat and 70s rather than the the step
of the presents you got to read it in
that context and not try to
immediately apply it to our situation
where psychoanalysis is pretty dead in
the water i mean
there are people still doing
psychoanalysis but cognitive stuff
has really taken over you know uh here
in america um my view on the works of
foucault so
foucault's kind of hit miss i like some
of his stuff
i think he's very prone to drawing two
sweeping conclusions
uh from the the sources that he uses
um sometimes he plays a little fast and
loose with the history
and you can tell if you're well versed
in the stuff that he's referencing
but he's often insightful i like i like
reading all these like
they've got these volumes they have like
his interviews and stuff like that
they're often really insightful um
so i i you know a sort of qualified
endorsement
of foucault right
all right um
andre says thoughts on shastav's opinion
in all things are possible on socrates
and pascal talking too much in their
last days for fear they should start
crying thus claiming the best death is
to die alone
i don't know i mean that that's chest
off of doing his his chest avian thing
um he he's probably the first who would
be willing to say
i could be totally wrong about this but
i'm going to say it anyway
you know so um i'll probably talk to you
know whoever's there
in in you know my room is i'm dying
but i'm a gregarious person and socrates
appeared to have been so as well
so all right
uh rt whitby did aristotle believe that
all of human actions were a means to the
ends of eudaimonia
i'll give you an example of one
[Music]
whistling is that is that a a means to
the end of eudaimonia
i don't think so not all not all action
is is
uh necessarily oriented towards the big
picture goal of eudaimonia
there's we're complicated creatures
right and there could even be
things that lead you away from
eudaimonia even though maybe you
mistakenly think that they're going to
lead you to it right
um shaparo says have i ever thought of
making a video about my experience
reading and engaging
with sir and kierkegaard's philosophy i
mean i could i never went through like a
kierkegaard
phase and i i don't know if it would be
all that
that interesting i could do that i guess
you know
um all right
uh i'm gonna skip over the peterson
thing since i've done that to death so
many times um
stephen asks quick question i come and
go to this channel but i thought you
were in the army what was your mos
i was a 12 bravo a combat engineer
and i was only in for a year and a month
i got out in the budget cuts of 1990
when we were realizing the peace
dividend shortly before
uh the the hussein thing started and
um yeah uh
being a 12 bravo combat engineer for
those who don't know
all this it means you do a lot of
infantry stuff
and so like i was also a grenadier i had
the you know
an m16 and then an m203 grenade launcher
that i had to qualify with and
we had to qualify with automatic weapons
and all sorts of other cool stuff as
well
but then engineers also do demolition
and setting up
obstacles and creating and blowing up
mine fields
and you know we were i was in germany
and so we were
essentially training to fight warsaw
pact
that's that's why our mission basically
ended right the soviet union fell apart
and warsaw pact
uh ended in the velvet revolution and
our life expectancy at that time was if
there was a war was 30 minutes
so i'm really glad there wasn't a war
because we were going to be like the
ones going
out ahead of the infantry and the armor
i was in the first armored division
and we probably would have gotten killed
because you know there were so many
soviet and warsaw packed forces
you know we were we were basically going
to be holding them back
until troops could be transferred in uh
from
from nato countries and from from the
states so
all right uh oh it's 122 here so i got
to start wrapping this up i'm going to
answer the next question and then i'm
going to jump around a bit because i do
have to end
uh at the hour and a half mark because i
have a
philosophy chat to prepare for with my
patreon supporters
all right um shigofumi what are you
planning for
one thous or one 100 000 subscriptions
you know i haven't actually given any
thought to them that's that's a great
idea
i should probably do something kind of
special like a party
you know i i i'm thinking i'll probably
do like a streaming thing like this
like i did for my 50th birthday bash or
there was another celebration i did when
i think i hit like
75 000 uh youtube
subscribers um so probably should
should do something like that so let me
grab
something else
from somebody who hasn't asked a
question um
let's see here
benjamin moon black says do you have any
tips for good reading practices for
philosophy or in general
yeah when you're reading philosophical
texts
you can't read them quite the same way
as you read other
works you should expect them to be more
difficult than say reading
a novel unless you're talking about
somebody's convoluted crazy novels that
you know i don't i don't really spend
time on those
but you know like more than like reading
a sci-fi novel
um so yeah there's there's there's that
don't expect to get everything out of
the text the first time
or the 20th time if it's a classic
like dostoevsky's notes from the
underground or you know
plato's symposium or
descartes meditations on first
philosophy
you're going to find stuff that you
missed on previous readings
and you're gonna have to keep going back
to it and that's okay that's normal
that's that's that's the way it is i
think a lot of
um a lot of my students they come into
class and they're very
anxious because they start reading the
stuff and they're like holy [ __ ] i don't
understand this at all you know and i'm
like
hey calm down don't worry about it you
don't have to understand it the first
time you read it
read it all the way through don't even
take any notes
now come back to it you know it's sort
of like getting to learn
a city that you you you know you've
never been in
and and you're going to figure out where
things are and what there is to see
you know you're not going to remember
everything right off the bat
so all right joseph messing what do you
think about the work of dietrich von
hill
hildenbrand he's a guy i've presented on
in the past
um actually at the dietrich von
hildenbrandt conferences when they used
to have him at
franciscan university steubenville i
like him he's he's
you know he's a student of mock shaler
and so he's doing some interesting stuff
with phenomenology
i think he's got some great insights
all right uh here's a good one from ivan
opinion on the current popularization of
stoic philosophy are people actually
limiting
themselves in philosophical development
by
being preoccupied with the discrete
practicality of stoic philosophy
totally depends on how they're doing it
right if they're like i only read stoics
then i'm like
no man you need to read more stuff
because the stoics read more than stocks
right and if you're reading watered-down
crap uh
sort of like stoicism sound bites or you
know
um people who are claiming that they're
going to like you know give you stoicism
in 10 easy steps
um you're not getting the straight dope
you're not getting real stock philosophy
as a matter of fact
let me put a plug in for steve
karafett's podcast the sunday stoic
i'm guest hosting tomorrow and i
recorded
about a 45-minute talk about why it's
important to actually read
actual stoic texts using seneca
and and how to do that you know um
so i think there is there is a danger
there there's quite a few dangers that i
think people can fall into
so that's a good question um
all right uh
who else can i address
fairly quickly um
so yeshua and pillay says i'm sure
you've read the lesser-known stoic
teachers like chrysippus or masonis
rufus what's your opinion on them
are they worth reading chrysippus you
can't read because we don't have
chrysippus's texts he was actually one
of the most prolific
authors of antiquity and we've got just
little extracts from him so
he's not and he's not a lesser known
star teacher he is the
second founder of the stoic school as as
he's called
missonius rufus um unfortunately we have
just some of his lectures
and then some fragments he's the teacher
of epictetus
uh was part of the stoic resistance to
nero
um well worth reading um definitely
worth checking out
there's other um people like hiracles
who you can get the works of
some of which are fragmentary um
there's there's a summaries of stoic
doctrine by people who aren't stoics
like arius didymus
you want to check that out too if you
can
cicero of course who's not a stoic
there's there's a number of works
in which he's providing us with
summaries of stoic doctrine sometimes
with his own
critical analysis so like you know on
duties
stoic paradoxes on the ends on
divination
on the nature of the gods if you're into
epistemology the academics although
it's kind of boring stuff and it's not
very helpful i think
um so yeah it's it's worth it's worth
reading these people
and um will i cover them in later videos
yeah i mean i've i have talked about um
some of this stuff in videos in stoic
week videos years ago
but sure i could i could do that i mean
it's a matter of getting around to it
there's so many
i mean i've done like 10 of seneca's
letters
seneca's got a whole bunch of other
letters that i should i should probably
do as well
all right um
[Music]
let's see here
here's an interesting one from john
kennedy
who would you say is a better story
writer camus or
sark that's a good question
you know and with sartre you have not
just
the novel well novels
and short stories but you also have
plays
um to talk about and some of the some of
the i mean like some of the plays are
really good
and some of them are not not
they haven't aged quite as well
if i had to pick between them i probably
would pick camus
um but that's not to say that sart isn't
any good and and why don't we throw
deburr into the mix too she's really
awesome and
i suppose we should probably throw
marcel right our four frenchies
um he's he's awesome as well so
um those those would be
some good works and and what part of
what i like about it so this is a good
way to close
existentialism is not just a
philosophical movement
it is also a literary movement and so
the literature
there's some things that you can
accomplish with literature
that you could maybe do in in straight
out philosophy but
it's easier to do in literature and you
can make things clearer
right and each of these thinkers gabriel
marcel
albert camus jean paul sartre simone
they recognized that that that was they
weren't just like doing stuff on the
side is like
this is my pet project they thought that
writing a play
was was an important philosophical
activity
all right so i didn't get to everybody's
questions but i think i probably got to
a bigger proportion
than in previous ones i'm going to go
and see what's going on outside because
i hear sirens and stuff like that
and find out what what's what's
happening here in the
great city of milwaukee i hope all of
you
have a great day i'm actually doing
another live streaming tomorrow where
i'll be talking much more about
political stuff
doing our political theory and practice
at 12 central
maybe i'll see some of you there but
thanks for all the questions and i'll
see you
somewhere in the ether